good morning John online video has
always been about relatable authentic
even independent content that's the
fascinating part right that anybody can
do this but can they it has gotten much
harder and the perception of it has
gotten much more mainstream to be both
authentic and relatable becomes very
hard when you're doing this
professionally there's not much less
relatable than being the CEO of a media
company and I'm the CEO of a media
company now I don't really know how that
happened with VidCon and scishow and
crash course and dftba records and all
of our other productions we have like 30
employees now now this is still solidly
a small business like we have fewer
employees than the average McDonald's
but I've had a lot of problems in the
last year that are super unrelatable
that I'm not going to talk about in
videos nobody wants to hear me like
whine about how complicated it is to
figure out how to properly classify
employment insurance for crash course
freelancers I love YouTube I love all of
YouTube but I really love the
independent weird stuff where someone
finds a niche or a format that's just
perfect for their skills and their style
the super Carlin brothers after years of
making content for a very small audience
recently found a format that has become
hugely successful and Bill word says
history of Japan is a weird art piece
from a creator that came out of nowhere
that I think everybody should watch but
when we started there was a lot of
attention and next to no content so it
was really easy to get noticed now it
could hardly be more crowded and then
I'm a one thing you need to get
attention is attention and most of the
people and companies who have attention
want to turn that attention back on
themselves or to sell it to advertisers
if you're making great content but
nobody's seeing it it's harder and
harder to get a leg up we do some of
that with things like the financial diet
and health care triage and sexplanations
and animal wonders and of course we got
the vlogbrothers ad revenue grants this
month we sent money to science with Tom
internally curious Simon ox fizz and
UNAC Adam E which is India's largest
free education initiative but it's
always easiest to turn attention and
money to new things that we are doing
like nerdcon or dear Hank and John or
scishow and crash course and of course
we love those things we think they're
good for the world and we love doing
them and that they're things that we do
with this community but they are
businesses in in their more traditional
productions you know like there's a
management structure and people work
together to create something rather than
like vlogbrothers which is just I write
stuff and then I talked some stuff and
then I edit some stuff and upload some
stuff it seems like the spirit of
YouTube to me and it seems maybe a
little bit unfair that someone like me
can use the money and attention that I
have to launch new projects and and to
bring people together talented awesome
people to help me create new things the
vast majority people don't have access
to those resources so they can't compete
with that pure meritocracy that's maybe
part of the mythology of YouTube is long
gone and one has to wonder whether that
is one creating frustration and two
decreasing the number of people who are
taking chances to do weird amazing
wonderful things on this platform that
nobody really knows what YouTube is but
I think that the the best analogy at
least for the creative personality
different parts is the music industry
you're gonna have at the top like a
rotating cast of really well-known
people and a few different really big
genres it's gotta make great content
it's gonna be polished and appealing and
lots of people are gonna love it but
it's gonna be maybe a tiny bit bland and
then there will be cascading levels down
of people who have smaller but more
dedicated audiences who perform in
subgenres or genres you might have never
heard of or you're just outside of any
genre and they'll be doing the really
creative weird interesting stuff that
will sometimes I'm sure bubble up to the
top and affect everything usually they
won't and that's why I think it's so
important that we use tools like patreon
to support creators like that for you
and me John I just think it's important
that even though not everything in our
lives has remained normal and super
relatable and we have pretty weird lives
now that we nonetheless remain authentic
and maybe we lose a little bit of our
own ability because of that but that's
reality I want to be open with the
people of this community and this video
is part of that John I'll see you on
Tuesday